remember back in lesson two when
Catherine used an async task hooked up
to a refresh button to update our data
rate Oh talked about how that was a bad
idea because the async task is not tied
to the activity lifecycle the virtual
machine will hold on to the activity
object as long as the async task is
running
even after Android is called ondestroy
for the activity and expect it to be
discarded if you rotate your phone the
behavior is to destroy your activity and
instantiate a new one the naive async
task implementation now has two threads
trying to perform the same update and so
forth the point is it's not the best
pattern for a potentially very long
background operations such as fetching
from web services if you leave the app
the async task will continue to run for
as long as your processes kept alive but
will run at a low priority and your
process will be the first thing to be
killed if the device needs more
resources and there's a bigger problem
your app has to be visible and running
in the foreground to instantiate the
task in the first place because we
started a task to update the weather
when we started the app this can have
undesirable behavior if the weather
changes rapidly so now we're going to
learn the right way to perform updates
we'll want to automate the process while
the app is in the foreground but even
more importantly we want the app to get
regular updates in the background with
minimal battery drain that will be
especially important later in this
lesson when you introduce weather
notifications